denn jetzt mal nach berlin zu meinem
kollegen alexander keller alexander also
diese geschichte mit diesem hin und her
in thüringen das ist das eine das andere
ist hanna und dieser terroranschlag
dieser rassistische terroranschlag und
da laviert eine afd hin und her was will
man denn nun glauben das was der
körperteil vorsitzende gestern dazu
gesagt hat dass die partei sich da jetzt
vielleicht auch ändert oder ist das
wieder nur so ein manöver ja die frage
ist ob macht dem gleich gezeigten
interview mit alexander gauland hier das
wirklich klar ist diese frage stephan
kulle die afg hat ja gestern versucht
noch zu retten was zu retten ist
mit diesem brief von kino copala und
jörg morgen den beiden
parteivorsitzenden dass es sehr wohl ein
rassistischer anschlag in hanau war
normalerweise kurzer hinweis von mir
noch findet die pressekonferenz hier
hinter mir im haus der
bundespressekonferenz mit beiden
parteivorsitzenden stadt jörg leuten und
timo grub aller juden ist allerdings
erkrankt deswegen springt der
ehrenvorsitz der partei alexander
gauland ein der ja in letzter zeit sich
auch nicht aufs altenteil zurückziehen
konnte sondern immer wieder mal als
krisenmanager eingesprungen ist bei all
den auseinandersetzungen bei den
ereignissen die sie gerade auch schon
angesprochen haben als vor wenigen
minuten seine dienstlimousine hier vor
dem haus der bundespressekonferenz vor
vorstand eine phoenix kamera direkt
daneben ein interview mit alexander
gauland kurz zur wahl in hamburg knapp
in der bürgerschaft darin 5,3 prozent
zeigt auch mit verlusten dass die bäume
der afd nicht in den himmel wachsen ist
hamburg ein schlechtes therapie ihre
partei tradition hanseatische gelassen
schafft wirtschaftlicher wohlstand kommt
da die kfd nicht so richtig auf ihr
wahlergebnis wir haben immer in
norddeutschland schwierigkeiten gehabt
dass das gilt hamburg für bremen das
gilt
niedersachsen von daher ist das ergebnis
aber sehr gut ich hatte sogar noch ein
schwächeres ergebnis befürchtet
denn bei der art von ausgrenzung und
derart auch entschuldigung von hetze
gegen uns zeigt ist dass wir eine
stammwählerschaft haben die auf jeden
fall zu uns hält und das ist das gute
ergebnis von hamburg in stichworten
ausstellung zum und hetze komme ich
gleich noch die sagen noch ein
schwächeres ergebnis das aber bedeutet
dass die afc aus der bürgerschaft
rausfliegt das war nicht völlig
auszuschließen
nach den ereignissen von thüringen und
hanau das damit musste man rechnen zu
thüringen es den raf die ja viel
schadenfreude ausgelöst dass politiker
von cdu und fdp der afg auf den leim
gegangen sind bei der wahl des
ministerpräsidenten andererseits wurde
damit aber auch dem parlamentarismus
insgesamt einen bärendienst erwiesen
denn immerhin haben sie einen kandidaten
aufgestellt den sie dann gar nicht
gewählt haben ist das auch etwas was
ihnen in hamburg geschadet hat er sich
völlig anders
wir haben einen kandidaten aufgestellt
er hatte keine chance also haben wir den
demokratischen kandidaten gewählt die es
zur wahl stand das ist ganz normale
demokratie das ist ganz normaler
parlamentarismus den zirkus den frau
merkel da angestellt hat aus südafrika
den finde ich beschämend für die
demokratie
man kann dinge nicht zurücknehmen und
deswegen thüringen hat uns nicht
geschadet es hat uns hanau mehr
geschadet sondern wir haben uns da ganz
demokratisch verhalten
warum haben sie dann überhaupt einen
kandidaten aufgestellt wird er keine
chance hat der kann die der kandidat
wurde aufgestellt als wir noch nicht
wussten dass es einen anderen kandidaten
der bessere chancen hat sich zur wahl
stellt kann man ja nicht wissen vorher
zu hanau
gestern hat der ihr nachfolger im amt
des parteivorsitzenden tino keller einen
brief geschickt an alle fdp mitglied und
gesagt sehr wohl wahr hanau ein
rechtsextremistischer fremdenfeindlicher
ausländerfeindlicher anschlag eine
mutmaßliche tat dieses täters mit neun
toten damit steht er diametral zu in die
gesetze die sie gesagt zu ihnen der
gesagt hat das war die tat eines
wahnsinnigen wieso fällt dann der
parteivorsitzende dem ehrenvorsitzenden
der afg so den rücken
das habe ich überhaupt nicht so gesehen
ich habe den brief war vorher gelesen
das eine schließt das andere nicht aus
es ist ein völlig verrückter es ist ein
mensch der offensichtlich
verschwörungstheorien nachhängt und
rassismus ist natürlich auch eine
verschwörungstheorie von daher ist es
völlig richtig was her grob allah und
vermauerten geschrieben haben und es ist
in keiner weise konträr zu dem was wir
alle sagen dass es zugleich können sie
auch in den zeitungen lesen
ein kranker ihrer gewesen ist wenn man
hat sich an den tagen nach auch noch so
verstanden dass sie den
rechtsextremisten für
rechtsextremistische motiv grundsätzlich
in abrede gestellt haben das habe ich
nirgendwo gesagt ich weiß nicht ob ein
verrückter wirklich ein politisches
motiv hat dass das was er zum teil zu
papier gebracht hat auch
rechtsextremistisches enthält das habe
ich nie bestritten
der frühere parteivorsitzende in berlin
tasci hat jetzt gesagt mehr konservativ
mögliches profil des geschäfts werden
klare abgrenzung gegen rechtsaußen ist
es auch eine abgrenzung dann gegen
perücke in keiner weise sind die ecke
ist nicht rechtsextremistisch und
rechtsaußen ich habe immer gesagt es
gibt eine bürgerliche mehrheit zum
beispiel in thüringen
das heißt es ist völlig klar dass es
gerecht dass wir eine bürgerliche partei
sind und dass man dieses profil auch
schaffen oder sehen die anderen parteien
an dass fdp und fatal für kann ich aber
nichts habe so die art und fragen
ja also da sehen die parteien cdu und
fdp anders natürlich werden sie es
anders sehen und hanau und thüringen hat
sicherlich die fdp und die cdu in dem
vorhaben bestärkt sich von der afg ganz
ganz klar abzugrenzen bezug auf hanauer
haben wir hier von alexander gauland
eine art rückzug in raten gesehen dass
also jetzt auch in der fdp der afg
entschuldigung eingesehen wird dass es
eben nicht nur die tat eines psychisch
kranken war sondern sehr wohl politisch
rassistische motive hatte ja soweit hier
jetzt zunächst mal von der
bundespressekonferenz und von der afg
die allerdings jahr um 10 uhr 30 also in
wenigen minuten ihre pressekonferenz
abhalten wird da ist auch noch der
spitzenkandidat der knochenmann dabei
der spitzenkandidat der wahl in hamburg
aber sicherlich wird sich auch das gros
der fragen an die beiden als die
politiker vom bund also tino keller der
bundesvorsitzende und alexander gauland
der ehrenvorsitzende vor allen dingen
auf hanau und auf thüringen sehen davon
können wir konzentrieren
davon werden wir ausgehen können bis
dahin zunächst noch mal zurück zu
stephan kulle nach bonn